ha pasado años tratando de ganar poder
militarmente ahora del mariscal califa
haftar apunta a las urnas este martes el
hombre fuerte del este de libia anunció
su candidatura presidencial para las
elecciones de diciembre una apuesta que
seguramente enfurecerá a muchos en el
oeste del país
y anunció mi candidatura a las
elecciones presidenciales no para buscar
poder o estatus sino para liderar a
nuestro pueblo en un momento crucial
para lograr el orgullo el desarrollo y
la prosperidad de aquí guardo mi
conexión hasta septiembre captar estuvo
al mando de una fuerza llamada ejército
nacional libio que ha librado por años
la guerra contra los grupos occidentales
bajo su mando lanzó una ofensiva de 14
meses en trípoli en abril de 2019 y fue
acusado de crímenes de guerra durante el
asalto renunció a su cargo para cumplir
con la ley electoral pero su candidatura
sigue siendo polémica y es probable que
genere sospechas de interferencia
electoral en las regiones del este que
aún controla haftar fue alguna vez un
jefe militar bajo el mando del ex
dictador amar gadafi ahora se enfrentará
al hijo de su ex jefe
salva al islam gadafi se postuló el
domingo el mismo es una figura
controvertida buscada por la corte penal
internacional la elección del 24 de
diciembre será la primera votación
presidencial directa de libia y la
esperanza es que pueda pasar la página
tras una década de conflicto